congratulations on an awesome season it
was uh it was really epic what was your
reaction when you saw how the season was
going to be playing out how the hell are
we going to get out of this that was the
first thought was like how is it ending
because when steve said that the world
was collapsing within itself or
something was going to start that was
going to make you know that it deals
outside of manpower
i was like how in the world are we just
going to sit down and pray like that was
i was confused for most of the season
while we were filming because of the
pandemic we actually had to
rejig the schedule multiple times and we
were shooting bits from episode four and
then a bit from episode eight and a bit
from episode two and i was just like
where are we for half the time but then
to sort of see it all come together on
the screen and
i was like oh wow it worked
somehow that's true we were shooting
like first day was like we shot
something from episode four yeah exactly
true your team is good but i don't think
you're better than me
i ended the world twice and you you're
just meeting spandex the transition that
victor has at the very beginning of the
season is really really remarkable
really powerful what was your reaction
when you either read those scripts or
saw how it came together i remember just
making sure i was off book
because it was such a powerful scene and
i was like i need to i just need to make
sure i give it as much effort as i as i
can because i felt like it was part of
history tv history at least of being
able to give justice a certain
theme and in the end you know i was just
really
excited
you know and especially how they were
handling it i was so excited to actually
be able to be a part of it what was the
energy like on the day it was fun it was
like you know at least that's we we
weren't thinking like oh my god this is
it wasn't until cheryl dunye said
you're just so you guys know you guys
are being you guys are part of a moment
in history
just so you guys know and it was like
oh yeah you know but because you know
elliot has been elliot to us since we've
you know since i met him so it was kind
of just you know just going and doing a
scene
yeah
yeah it was really it was as i said
really really beautiful you could feel
the love coming through it radiates in
those moments yeah um
justin what was it like for you to play
this version of of ben
evil ben bad ben what is
what are we calling him don't judge sir
don't
misunderstood ben
everybody else could see ben right yeah
and he's a complete [ __ ]
they're all [ __ ]
[ __ ] who can fight
next person to say [ __ ] is getting a
punch to the throat dick [ __ ]
[ __ ] it was a blast uh you know i
think as an actor you're always hoping
for
challenges and and hoping to be
stretched and i don't think i could have
been more stretched than
with the season to play a sort of
totally different version of this
character who i had known for two
seasons and to sort of prep for it both
physically and vocally was a lot of fun
and of course to be able to finally act
alongside some of my co-stars who i've
known for two seasons but never got to
really be in scenes with was was a lot
of fun as well yeah yeah um
i mean david this season you got your
character
has well doesn't have a son but kind of
has a son
which is a pretty uh i mean what a what
like fantastic performance that uh that
young man gave and javon he's incredible
in
uh euphoria he's a fantastic
boxer like what was it like spending
time with him talking about that
experience of working with him oh he was
so humble and so excited and so curious
and uh such a he really worked hard and
he would beat himself up you know at mo
at times we were doing scenes and it was
you know pulling him to the side be like
dude like you're doing great because
he's just so like i you know it just
needs to feel right
and you know
bonding with him outside of the set was
something that i really really enjoyed
like you know we would do boxing on the
weekends
and watching his skill as a boxer i mean
he shows up set and he's he's a kid but
when he boxes you're like oh he can beat
a man up
yeah yeah
i mean you've got you you're like
diego's had like a bunch of action
scenes did he ever like go hey man just
uh you're not turning your fist over
enough you know you make it he looks
good we want to make it look a little
better yeah no he
he never he was so humble that he never
said that but he would say like he was
probably thinking it yeah he would like
came up to me he's like you know i could
probably beat your ass
[Laughter]
because i was like you probably could i
was like yay
yeah thank you for that what was it like
shooting the footboost scene there's
been dance numbers in the past but like
this i feel like raised the raised the
bar on it it was it was so good yeah
talk to you talk about your experience
it was terrifying it was terrifying uh
for me as
someone who can't and never dances
um it was
incredible for people like david who
loves to dance and is very skilled at it
but it was a lot of fun i mean it was
the first big set piece that we all
filmed together with both the sparrows
and the umbrellas and it was this kind
of
real bonding experience um through the
rehearsal process and then finally being
able to film on the day i don't think i
could ever listen to footloose ever
again because
yeah you know it's just
yeah no i just remember like just
thinking while we were rehearsing just
thinking of my mom saying like move your
hips use your hips
you know you know and and
again shout out to our incredible
choreography team headed by john because
like
he really worked with us and like
figured out ways to move our bodies in
ways that i don't think any of us
thought was possible you make me feel
exactly right
sure like a natural woman when we jumped
here we created a time paradox our
little paradox brought forth the
freaking kugelblitz what the hell is the
cougar blitz essentially we're screwed
when we finally uh get to the end of the
season
and it seems like the universe is saved
and reset
when everybody comes to uh i guess comes
through the door it seems like there's
no one has any powers what can you tell
me about where this heads in the next
season
what do you want to see for your
characters as they sort of head off into
the world as
normal yeah powerless people dude i
really i just had this idea and i i kind
of wish that like
because of this missing of not even to
use knives that he ends up being some
sort of pacquiao
you know like half like like trying to
work at a taco place you know in mexico
and him just trying to like you know
really trying to he's angry he's trying
to chop up the meat you know in mexico
city you know like just something like
that where he's trying to relive his
best moments like an al bundy and ben
works at a sushi restaurant um and every
time he sees an octopus he starts
sobbing well we do get a little we do
have i think it's the coda in this yeah
in the season of ben
i think it's ben on the on a train
reading a book right what can you tell
me about this can you give me any
insight into this i would love to um
unfortunately i don't know much
that scene was completely
shot in secrecy and mystery um so i
don't really know where that version of
ben is and what he's doing i do know
that he's in korea
uh
and that's about it yeah it's funny
because he does know but he's just so
well at keeping information
and that's the scary part
right i mean i i'm sure i'm for you
don't
don't lie to me either tell me
[Music]